a deleted demon creepy motel visitors
and a post-credits teaser setting up the
next conjuring movie are some of the
many scenes cut from the devil made me
do it
yupikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video i'm revealing the fascinating
scenes original ending and villain cut
from the conjuring three
spoilers for the franchise ahead so take
care
in a departure from the haunted house
theme of the first two conjuring movies
the devil made me do it as more of a
demonic detective story with edin
lorraine searching for clues that will
eventually lead them to the occultists
underground lair
however in the trailers there's a good
deal of footage that points to an
alternate storyline for how the warrens
discover the occultist den
notice how the trailer shows ed and
lorraine opening the door together on
her altar
compared to the final movie where
lorraine finds the room by herself
after she goes to visit castner alone
and he reveals to her the truth about
his daughter and the tunnels
in this earlier version of the movie the
location also looks quite a bit
different
there's what looks like a tree behind
the altar plus an animal which could be
a goat or perhaps even a ram given we
know the occultist developed her
interest in satanism from the objects
her father collected while investigating
the disciples of the ram
ed also carries a package with him into
the room which he uses to sweep
everything off the occultist altar in
this deleted scene
in the final movie ed doesn't arrive at
the altar room until the very end when
he's under the influence of the
occultist and is attacking lorraine
and after lorraine breaks him out of
that trance he smashes the altar with a
sledgehammer
some behind the scenes footage also
shows another different version of
lorraine going to the altar room by
herself than we guess in the finished
movie
we know this was deleted because
lorraine's hair is up in this shot
rather than down as it is in the final
film at this point and she's also got a
bandage on her hand
an intriguing deleted scene teased in
the trailer but which never made it into
the final film is of ed and lorraine
during their stay at a motel while
investigating the jessica and katy case
in this cut scene ed is on the phone but
lorraine has been distracted by
something
a row of creepy shadows outside the
motel window which feel like they're
looking in on the warrens
you can tell this is a motel and not the
warren house because of the do not
disturb sign on the doorknob and i think
this could have been another of the
optical illusions that the occultist is
able to perform
a particularly cool moment teased in the
trailers which sadly didn't make it into
the final film was this shot of multiple
copies of lorraine endlessly spiraling
into the distance
this would have been a visual trick cast
by the occultist while she was pursuing
lorraine through the tunnels
this moment was foreshadowed during the
opening scenes of david's exorcism
when the camera that drew was filming
with was knocked over as the camera
continued to record the monitor it was
connected to
an image of the screen began to
replicate itself infinitely
in a very similar pattern to what
happens to lorraine in this deleted
scene
in the final movie we get a kind of cut
down somewhat simplified version of this
trippy visual with a double of lorraine
appearing in front of her and mirroring
her movements
although this was still a nice effect
that suitably freaked lorraine out it's
a shame we didn't get the full-on
sequence teased at the beginning of the
movie
another deleted scene from the trailers
are these shots of the police searching
for a body
this is the water below the cliff that
lorraine nearly fell down while she was
investigating katie's murder at the hand
of jessica
these scenes were probably cut for
pacing and time in the final version
however they might also be another
indicator of reshoots in the movie
because it could explain why in the
final film
a bandage suddenly appears on lorraine's
hand after she almost falls off the
cliff
even though she didn't seem to hurt her
hand when ed rescued her
although it is possible it's an injury
from that fall it might hint that
something else happened to lorraine
during those deleted scenes
a curious deleted scene in one of the
trailers shows arnie standing on the
edge of a prison building with a chain
around his neck
looking like he might be about to kill
himself in the movie the occultist tries
to get arnie to commit suicide like
jessica when she ran off the cliff in
order to complete the curse she cast on
him
some fans were a little disappointed
that the devil made me do it didn't dive
so much into the details of arnie
johnson's court trial
and although i doubt it was ever going
to be the main focus there's some behind
the scenes footage of ed addressing
reporters outside the courthouse which
wasn't in the final movie
hinting there may have been more
courtroom drama filmed but cut from the
final film
a publicity still of lorraine ed drew
and debbie forming a prayer circle
indicates another scene that was nowhere
to be found in the final movie
this moment looks like it would have
appeared around the time that the
warrens and the team are trying to
figure out the key to breaking the curse
put on arnie by the occultist and i
suspect the prayer was cut for time
a major change that might explain why
there appear to have been reshoots on
the film is that in early versions of
the movie there was a specific demon
that the occultist was communicating
with
in the final film although a reference
is made to the occultist having summoned
a demon
this demon it's not here of its own free
will it was summoned we never see its
form
and instead at the end when the curse
has been broken it's a copy of the
occultist which comes to take her soul
in an interview with slash film director
michael chavez said they originally had
a demon that matched the description
that the real life david glatzel and
arne johnson had given to them about the
demonic entity they claimed to possess
them producer james 1 was on board with
the demon and a cut of the film with the
demon does in fact
exist however it appears that the
interaction between the demon and the
occultist was too complicated and
confusing for test audiences which
chavez puts down to this being the first
time a human antagonist has featured in
the franchise
at the time of filming chavez was
actually expecting the demon to end up
with his own spin-off film but admitted
that it just didn't click
and had to be replaced in a similar way
to how the original antagonist of the
conjuring ii
a winged horned demon ended up being
replaced by the demonic nun valak during
re-shoots
because chavez felt bad for the actor
davis osborne who'd played the original
demon he decided to give him the part of
the prison hospital patient who mocks
and taunts arnie
the devil made me do it also originally
had a post-credits scene that would have
set up a future conjuring universe movie
in an interview with nme chavez revealed
that the deleted credits teaser was an
expansion on the villains introduced in
this movie
however similar to the demon problem it
was confusing and therefore removed to
give the film a more solid definitive
ending
chavez hasn't yet said what was in the
scene but i wonder whether it could have
alluded to the return of valak in a
fourth conjuring movie or perhaps a
sequel to the nun
there were already a few teasers to
wallach in the film such as the nun
figurine in arnie's bedroom
but as titan br pointed out on my things
you missed video there was also this
photograph of the occultist when she was
younger and in the background towards
the window there seems to be a
mysterious shape which could be a blurry
and somewhat indistinct or
semi-transparent nun's habit
the date on the photograph is 1952 which
is the year that the main events of the
nun take place
something which suggests the filmmakers
want to tease a potential connection
between the two movies
we have seen the demonic nun hidden in
the background of a photo before in the
franchise for example in the one that
sister charlotte
showed to samuel mullins in annabelle
creation perhaps this post-credits scene
would have shown the occultist having
been previously in contact with valek in
some way
another possibility is that she was
visited by frenchie who in 1952 was
possessed by valak during the events of
the nun movie
alternately the credit scene might have
expanded on the connection between the
occultist and the disciples of the ram
the cult from the first annabelle movie
that was mentioned several times and the
devil made me do it
we know from father kastna the disciples
of the ram were especially evil and
vindictive and that after the cult's
members were tried and found guilty the
lead prosecutor's wife and baby both
suffered terrible fates
if any of the cult are still around or
if they can break out of prison
they might target ed and lorraine for
helping to take down the occultist
something that could be the setup for
the next country or annabelle movie
a master satanist is not an adversary to
be taken likely
the credit scene might also have been
setting up the crooked man spin-off
movie that's currently in development
based on the villain from the haunted
turntable in the conjuring 2.
whatever the scene entails we'll
hopefully get to see it as chavez said
the scene may be coming back
in another form hinting that it'll be
worked into an upcoming movie or perhaps
even as a deleted clip from the movie's
blu-ray release
and if you want to learn all about how
the devil made me do it connects with
the nun and the annabelle movies plus
all the horror movie easter eggs in the
film tap here to watch my things you
missed video or follow the link in the
video description
so do you wish any of these deleted
scenes have been in the final movie
and what conjuring film are you looking
forward to next
let me know in the comments below if you
enjoyed this leave a thumbs up and a
share is also
hugely appreciated tap left to discover
the even more horrifying original ending
of the none
or tap right for something else you're
sure to like thanks for watching and see
you next time yippie kai movie lovers